first handheld system I mean you
remember we had those little bush jordan
verse bird and stuff like that does
literally just had like three buttons on
them there break you know what I'm
saying but it never just had like you
you look like an inch of skin so you see
it just was like a shadow of a man hey
what's up GQ I'm Danny Brown and these
are my essentials okay everybody know
your phones and it works you know
today's technology man these are coming
us a lot of people have one phones
actually have three you gotta have
different phones for different things
you know I have one for family you know
just like you know real important
business you gotta have that but it's
you know what I'm saying so that you
know it's like the bat signal then this
is just like for you little random you
know everyday people you know you meet
on the street you be like yeah you'll
take my number you know that invades get
people figures with the ladies give me
real number but you don't block on my
don't answer when I do stuff like that
and I have a third phone just for
streaming I didn't know there's gonna be
on live stream or something just make it
was taking like I don't know it's a dick
pic or something it's over you gotta
have another phone for just you know
only social media and stuff and that's
just said so that's that
next is headphones and you want to get
you a good pair here for good sound
quality I like audio technique to ask my
favorite company and you know you're on
the plane is and babies and crying and
stuff you want something that noise
canceling you know what I'm saying
you're wondering when you can hear them
up for conversation and hear what they
got to say so you gonna get you a nice
big fair audio Technica's drown out
babies crying on the plane you know what
I'm saying you could go into your own
world you know I'm saying do what you
got to do what you said go plane
watching you know I'm saying oh no go
out the street guys something like that
I don't know it's one of my favorite
shows by the way baby video games man
will probably be my number one
it was to go with what you know you
can't live without video games you know
you're feeling down and depressed guys
alternative world you can turn to it
it's the world of video games like right
now I'm playing Fire Emblem very very
very very deep storyline you know what
I'm saying I'm really getting drawn into
it when I wouldn't care about what's
going on the outside were you notice it
breath with a wild it's amazing it's a
10 out of 10 game you know I'm saying I
just you know I hate it every time you
know you go cook up something you know
I'm saying throw a couple apples you
throw step in the pot baby come on some
wood you know what I'm saying I wasn't
very good at cooking on there so that
was my downfall about Zelda Breathitt
about xscape light bit yes it's really
overrated thanks of arena
video games
[Music]
I want steak man when you first start
making you a little bit of money
whatever let me do them you got any good
splurge or something no one thing you
wouldn't probably do is get you a nice
watch me personally I'm a fan of like
rare vintage watches and stuff like that
I don't like that you know the big card
I'm actually this is a rare Jacob but I
have here's a Domino's Pizza Rolex it
was a thing where I think if you so
certain amount of pieces from fabric
Domino's the actual owner of Domino's
with getting this Rolex they know I've
got it at a pawn shop
so I guess somebody so they frighten the
dreams would wait for nothing you know
you slug all those pizzas matter to get
the trophy you know to save you just
give it away to my dumb ass that's cool
okay I guess next would be foot we're
right in general she's like look yeah
nice you know a lot of people snicker
here to self and have a nice pristine
pair but in 1985 Jordan woods you know
not a red truck I could be walking up
the street right Nadia's mother just
literally fall apart on my foot you know
I'm saying but I take the risk for
fashion you know what I'm saying but as
we want to go where the Jordan one of
centuries of the George 1/5 you know I'm
saying eternities
you can't go no room with a pair of
Birkenstocks you know what I'm saying
these are like the air Moses is one's
gladiators you to feel the knees are you
imagine running around stabbing love
with swords and ease Michael Jordan just
dumped they stabbed the [ __ ]
Eve's you give it up said so you need to
get you a pair of burger stocks you know
what I'm saying specially if you 30 get
you a pair of Brooklyn shots and let the
toes breathe very nine here you know
what I'm saying better for your health
[Music]
just leave you know because no trees
create air and oxygen for us and it's
like a part of life you know a very
uplifting when you get down sometimes
you need to leave
cures my anxiety my depression you know
makes me feel real better about myself
sometime when I'm down so shuts up to my
leaves and trees and all my fighting
this you know botanists are underrated
you know I'm saying people need to
support your local botanist the next
thing we're just coming hygienic
essentials you know I'm saying one
number one thing is loathsome to Spencer
for a black man whom you can't be
walking around you know what I'm saying
isn't making mixed in there you got an
itching harm you're scratching your like
you've been raffling with a cheetah you
know the same so you gotta keep some
lotion on deck you know I'm saying yeah
bumpers a minor in the street you say
what's up dog and you just eat you give
them that look a handshake with the hood
thing if you like
like a t-shirt it had like a deodorant
pad that you might adjust change that
you would never go musty you know you
would never stay
come on me I can't be given aborted game
for free next is water I mean obviously
you know water is the key to life
without water I don't know what I do but
I'm a huge fan of sparkling water you
know who says I was in Europe one time I
can't remember where I was at you know
part again got a little too drunk you
know your new hotel bed you just knock
doggy door room is spinning then you
reach out you grab a bottle of water but
I didn't know it was a sparkling water
if that talent wasn't fans properly
water like that you know and I just goes
with it darling i guzzled it down and
next thing I know I just projectile
vomited all over the room you know what
I'm saying anything that can make you do
that it got all the poison out of me I
feel like such a better man if anything
that can do that maybe that's something
I need to be drinking more so ever since
then I just been drinking sparkling
water every nurse is just bags you know
you first get you a little money man you
want to get you a nice watch and you
also want to get you a nice bag - I
remember man back in the day we used to
tie a sheet to a stick the next lady
used to move around the streets you know
what I'm saying with a stick and it was
a sheep now we got these book bags with
all these secret compartments and
pockets a good it's I would say this you
know cats up here it's just bitter in
general this would be more so just like
you know walk around like I don't know
condoms and stuff you know this you can
you know I put more electronics in just
like my video games you know stuff like
that you know music stuff you know I
would say I'm a fan of the Louie Vuitton
stuff because it's durable
I'm I've had this back forever for years
I feel like this Warren has lived in it
it's part of me now at this point and
just feel you know still holding up
doing you got a do you know
next we got in a kingdom because you got
to read bucks man like remember back in
the day you pray carry one book I've
used walking around with 20 books in
your bag gonna be like a serial killer
sir know what I'm saying now I've like a
hundred books right here can just flick
through and just switch the different
books you knew them soon I'm reading
like three books at a time shot some of
my books and girls like that man I can
read you know what I'm saying so you got
it even if you're not reading for real
you know what I'm saying if you want to
pick up some chicks just get you a
bookshelf I just go by random books I'm
like a thrift so you don't got to read
them a nothing you know and girl come
over you know you got books so she's
like I gotta trust you got books so yeah
you gotta have some folks Thank You GQ
thank you for having me through we save
it a king have a nice time talking about
my essentials well you got
[Music]